the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising was the
largest single revolt by Jews during
World War two Nazi Germany cleared the
Jewish quarter of the city with brutal
force thousands were killed and anyone
who survived was taken to a
concentration camp several hundred
children were smuggled out of the ghetto
by the Polish resistance and survived
our reporter met two of them in Warsaw
yana sobolevskaya piece was four years
old when she was rescued from the warsaw
ghetto she was saved by Polish
resistance fighters it would be years
before she discovered how lucky she'd
been this is me this is her earliest
photo taken after the occupation her
Jewish parents had her smuggled out of
the ghetto something she no longer
remembers my father was called Green
spawn and my mother Zilber but how did
you discover what had happened to you
I found family members in Israel after I
first heard the old family names
I wrote to an Israeli newspaper and
that's how I found an uncle one day
prior to the ghetto uprising Sobolev
capice was brought to a Polish
resistance fighter here in Warsaw a
woman who found adoptive parents for
Sobolev Skippy's her new parents had her
baptized as Catholic it wasn't until her
18th birthday that she found out about
her Jewish origins wanting to learn more
about her parents
so that obscure piece contacted the
former resistance fighter she told me
you have to be grateful to the sober
left skis for raising you and for
allowing you to study she stressed the
role the sober left skis played but I
wanted to find out as much as possible
about my biological family this wasn't
easy
after the ghetto uprising in 1943 the
Nazis had nearly all remaining Jewish
survivors deported to concentration
camps almost all were murdered
today a monument commemorating the
ghetto and its 300,000 killed
inhabitants marks the location where the
infamous footbridge once connected the
large and small quarter here Jewish
people lived densely packed the German
occupiers didn't allow them to exit the
ghetto without permission and yet Polish
resistance fighters managed to smuggle
Jewish children out past the guards the
fate of these children is being
researched by the Poland Museum of the
history of Polish Jews in Warsaw
including the fate of Christina but
Natsuko when the ghetto uprising began
in 1943 but Natsuko was still inside it
she is one of its last surviving
witnesses and where was the bunker in
which you hid Christina it was on the
corner of salmon hopper Street and milla
Street it's always been hard for me to
get more information
I try to find out who on the so-called
Aryan side helped me to this day I don't
know which resistance fighters saved me
cause it's a gotta the secret council
for aid to Jews was it the Jewish
Committee I still don't know but Natsuko
was 11 years old when her siblings hid
her in a bunker that had been
constructed under the house at the time
two of her brothers had already been
deported and killed in the Treblinka
death camp
when the uprising began she went even
deeper to hide herself down into the
sewers while German occupying forces
attacked the Jewish resistance above
with flamethrowers and gas grenades but
'not scre now 85 stayed hidden below
with three others until she was saved by
resistance fighters we were brought
outside through sewage pipes and then
put into sacks why into sacks we don't
look human anymore we were just skin and
bones
we had no strength left
we had been underground for nine months
without light and without contact to the
outside world but she opted where is
this contact she was kept hidden until
the end of the war and then brought to
an orphanage today
Bhootnath seeker tells young people her
story to warn of right-wing extremism if
this big group goes into Warsaw and
bears witness to what I've told you then
I don't think anti-semitism can survive
it's in your hands I wish you well thank
you
Krystyna botnets car and yana
sobolevskaya piece are founding members
of the children of the Holocaust
Association they want to share their
story about life and death in the Warsaw
Ghetto as often as they can